welcome back to CBS mornings we have
another parenting segment now from
popular comedian and actor Sebastian
Maniscalco if you've seen any of his
stand-up routines you know he spends a
lot of time talking about his family and
young kids
my wife loves to dress my daughter up
man the outfits
I like a onesie
it's easy laid a baby in the onesie duck
the feeding
my wife told me could you dress her I'm
gonna take a shower I said yeah no
problem do you ever dress an infant
they have no core so it's
he is so right Sebastian his dad to
five-year-old Serafina and
three-year-old Caruso he's teamed up
with pediatrician Dr Scott Cohen the
author of Eat Sleep poop they launched a
parenting podcast called daddy versus
doctor sharing advice and their own
parenting Adventures take a look
today we are joined by Megan Daniel and
they have a child Abigail who does not
nap or sleep well and we're going to
take a little peek into what's going on
in their house let's take a look
it's magical it's amazing nothing
compares to the joy of actually becoming
a mom especially you know my little
abios mama
loving caring sometimes tiring and not
sometimes all the time tiring have a
good night from the first cry that
happened
[Music]
you're waking up like oh my God is she
okay
[Music]
quickly get out of bed and make sure you
know she's still breathing
it's like a thunderstorm that you didn't
expect
the sleep deprivation especially in the
middle of the night when you just know
that you're gonna wake up you know you
know in a little bit it's terrifying I'm
always searching online there's a lot of
information out there and everyone
claiming that this is right it was very
overwhelming the daily changes
um just kind of freaks you out
when someone asks what time does she not
I'm like oh this is a tough one
the Naps are a disaster right now we all
would be happy if she slept more
so let's talk about some sleep training
Did You Sleep Train okay we did when I
heard about sleep training
who needs that you just put the kid to
bed and you go to bed and I would be
real maternal like I would be sleeping
and I hear and I would be you know I was
up and I was looking at that monitor
like game tape honestly sleep training
is not for everybody because as a parent
it is heartbreaking because the idea of
sleep training is getting your child
after four months of age to sleep a
minimum of 10 hours can you imagine
sleeping 10 hours again right
um minimum of 10 hours without your
child feeding or picking them up
hello what do you do for your bedtime
routine she first starts starts playing
with her books
books sometimes when
she's a little more away
I love you she would scream her lungs
out for like half an hour straight and
she would just not go to sleep unless I
go and comfort her so uh when this
happens you got it set up where you go
into the room and then you go into the
room how is it the responsibilities
divvied up Mommy
because you you thought she was sleeping
through the night right this guy's like
my dad you do it
okay I'm a heavy sleeper so sometimes
she'll be like did you hear her I'm like
what she woke up no she he wakes up in
the morning he's like oh thank God
tonight she didn't wake up I'm like just
pretend you now exactly exactly yeah
it's crazy you seem like the softy are
you the softer I'm the song
listen I've gotten into the crib a few
times yeah I'm more the uh the kind of
the emotional one in the relationship
and very sensitive to the child where my
wife is no fear let them do whatever I'm
always like oh they're on the playground
I'm like oh they're gonna fall so you
cry when Abigail cries yes and it's it's
heartbreaking right and this guy
you want me to be honest you have a
child are you wearing it I comfort her I
don't cry but deep down somewhere in
that heart of mine I I you know I get a
little emotional at least when Abigail
cries and just by talking to you I bet
in this family Daniel's taking naps
in the crib with the baby
goes down she puts a boat down guilty
in a moment we're going to be talking
with Sebastian Maniscalco and Dr Scott
Cohen no shock here the dads in studio
Tony and Nate well they already I don't
know if they're getting advice or if
there's just a big exchange of ideas
going on who is speaking more we will
find out great advice coming up for you
with your little ones and sleep